hey Clinton Jones here and in this
tutorial what we're going to be learning
is how to have planes helicopters UFOs
whatever you want fly across the sky and
you know actually be able to motion
track it into the shot so it looks like
you know it looks realistic and it
doesn't look like it's just sitting in
this one spot even though the cameras
moving so we're going to be using we're
gonna be using After Effects mainly but
we are going to be using a 3d modeling
program so you can use Emma 4d 3ds max
you can use Maya you can I'm sure you
can use blender but let's go over what
we're gonna do so we have this shot here
of our actor are standing and basically
the camera just pans over as some
airplanes are gonna fly over here or you
know helicopters whatever you do want so
this kind of reminds me of opposing
force the old half-life game I love that
game alright but to start off you know
import your footage drag it into here to
make a new composition and what we need
to do is we need to set up a kind of
like a 3d a 3d set up for our planes to
you know integrate with this picture or
with this video and fly by so what you
want to do is go to the point in time
where you want the planes to fly by so
when the when the camera pans over here
they're going to start flying by so this
is when they're gonna start flying
across what we want to do is save this
frame out as a reference for our 3d
program so let's go to composition and
we will do save frame as now I already
have it saved out I just saved it as a
JPEG and I saved it to my desktop so
let's go into our 3d program okay I use
cinema 4d mainly for all my 3d stuff
like I said before you can use pretty
much any modeling program I think now I
have this jet here you can use like I
said you know before you can use a
helicopter or whatever you want but I'm
gonna use a jet because I think I look
pretty cool so
I got this jet from turbosquid calm
I got it free all you have to do really
is go to search and then you're gonna
want to click I guess aircraft and
you're gonna want to search for free
model so go sort by lower prices and
type in the file type you want for me it
would be C for D it might be 3ds or max
or you know whatever I know a cinema 4d
you can import 3d s files obj files and
the c40 files of course so just keep
that in mind when you're looking through
so just you want to go through here pick
out a nice model download it you have to
sign up as a member but it's free so you
can find some really good stuff on here
for free alright so once we have our
model imported here what we're gonna do
is make a couple changes so obviously
he's not landing so I'm going to delete
the landing gear and all that stuff you
know this month the model doesn't have
to be detailed really at all
it can just be kind of like a box model
style because it's gonna be flying you
know through the air pretty fast so
you're not really gonna tell so that's
the cool thing about it alright so we
have everything
you know we're mainly gonna be seeing
the bottom of this not really the top so
keep that in mind when looking for
models if it's you know you want to have
some detail down here you know some
rockets and the fuel tank and whatnot
now this is a bunch of different
polygons so let's if you're in cinema 4d
you can select the first one go down
just like the bottom one hit alt G and
that'll group it just name it like jet
or something alright so we have our jet
now let's set up that picture so what
we're going to do is go and make a new
plane and let's
scale the jet down
tell me where to go alright there we go
and you're gonna want to set the plane
width and height to you know the size of
your video so if you're an after effects
you can go to composition composition
and settings and you can see the width
and height of your video so let's set it
to 720 by 480
so 720 480 so this is basically just
your screen here let's rotate this 90
degrees on the eggs and if you hold down
shift you can go in increments of 5 I
believe all right so let's make a new
material this material came with a jet
it's on the jet right now so let's
double click that and in our color tab
we'll click this here and we will go and
find the picture we saved out in
after-effects of the scene right here
fly by frame just cancel that drag that
on the plane and you see there we go we
have you know our frame here so let's go
to the light up here and let's create a
new camera and we will set reset all
these coordinates down here to zero and
then we'll take the camera and pull it
back all right another important thing
you want to be in the camera view of
course so go cameras scene cameras
camera so you're in here but notice this
black bar right here when we render out
you're only going to be saying well if
we actually render it out you're only
going to be seeing from here to here
this is going to be cut off so we need
to fix that so let's go into our render
settings and go to the output and set
the width to 720 by 480 we'll go over
some of these settings later when we
actually render it out fine
you know a little bit so let's bring the
camera back if you click here you can
get off of camera view bring the camera
back some more and you probably want to
do like four view mode and pull it back
just enough to where you know you fit
right in so right about right about here
is good
it's pretty close see I'll find you a
little bit more you know you want to get
it pretty accurate that's pretty good
right there all right
so we ever seen here let's actually now
we won't do that I was gonna put a lock
on the camera but let's not do that
because we might have to move it
so we have our jet right let's yeah
let's rotate our camera wrong one yeah
let's rotate it about because notice the
shot you know we're looking up so the
camera is rotated you know to be
pointing up so let's change that so the
camera is actually pointing up maybe
let's try 15 degrees and then rotate the
plane another 15 then we'll just bring
it up and we'll reset our camera you
know just so we're in a frame here so
that we were kind of looking up at this
jet it's kind of hard to see let's
rotate our jet and this is when we have
to match it in to the scene so now we
can actually put a lock on our camera so
go to cinema 4d tags and just select
protection here that way you can't move
the camera all right so let's take our
jet let's scale it down and notice we're
looking at the bottom of the jet we
might want to rotate it up just a little
bit we're gonna have this flyby right
over and that's probably too big so
let's scale it down to maybe here
because this thing's gonna be pretty low
coming right over this rooftop
maybe a little less
yeah that's pretty good so let's rotate
it a little bit so it's flying kind of
kind of like this and let's um alright
alright let's do let's animate this guy
so we're gonna bring him back and even
though you can't see it it's just going
behind this thing so just bring it back
all the way here if you turn this off
you know he's still back there so and
that's key from this guy so select your
jet and let's make a key frame on frame
0 by the way and go to frame 15 bring
him forward out this way make another
keyframe so now we have them animated
it's pretty fast
let's take it to 20 because we can
always you know we can speed it up a
little in After Effects maybe 25 yeah 25
is cool so let's duplicate this a couple
times
um ctrl-c ctrl-v and we will reposition
this guy so that you know there's two
planes flying over in you know different
directions at different times so let's
delete these keyframes for this
duplicate here and let's bring forward
some so we can actually see it and we're
gonna rotate it like this
and we're going to bring it up some
and maybe over this way we'll have to do
some basking but it'll make it look cool
so let's bring them back here and let's
go like frame eight we'll set a keyframe
move forward to frame thirty three or
something and let's move this guy over
here let's see what this looks like very
cool very cool all right so what do we
let's actually let's take this guy here
and let's keyframe his rotation so once
again we'll set a keyframe move here and
we will rotate him on the what we do
let's let's rotate him Mike like that is
something really small it's very small
uh-huh let's undo that it's too small to
notice and he's already in an angle so
let's let's duplicate maybe one more
kind of up here but maybe a lot higher
so go back to frame 0 we'll duplicate
this again ctrl-c ctrl-v will delete the
keyframes and then we'll bring this guy
where is he right now this guy is
probably in front of the shot yeah there
he is ok let's bring him over here let's
pull him back over bring him pull him
way back bring him up here back some
more now if you take the plane off you
can see he's kind of way up here so
let's keyframe him let's rotate him this
way
and bring him all the way back here way
back here and we'll start him on frame
eight as well set a keyframe and we'll
go to frame 45 and get this guy across
the screen
boom so he's going fast when he's just a
little higher you know let's see what it
looks like all right let's take this jet
number two and make it 60 frames let's
even go 75 because that he's going
really fast
we'll go 80 and call it call it 80 yeah
all right so let's save our work don't
forget to save your work because if it
crashes I think my computer does a lot
it's not good you lose on your work okay
so now let's talk about the export
settings so you know we talked about
output 720 by 480 we're going to do what
are we gonna do we've gotten to frame 80
with our animation let's just go - you
know won't worn out the whole thing so
let's go all frames you can do manual
frames or just manual if you'd like you
know so you not to run out the whole
thing and let's see framerate 30 you
want to keep it the same as your source
footage once again you can check this by
going to composition settings and it's
actually 29.97 which is 30 pretty much I
don't know if you can type in 29.9 zone
okay you can let's also check our aspect
ratio 1.21 widescreen so 1.21 let's undo
that I don't think that we can we can
work with us in After Effects save let's
save it I'm just going to save it to my
desktop call it Jets I usually save it
as a QuickTime movie we're going to save
it as an animation 29.97 for the frames
per second we're going to change this to
millions of colors plus and this will
give us an alpha channel so we don't
have to key any thing out you don't do
it for us and check this for alpha
channel animals have an automatic alpha
channel which is very nice auntie Alison
I'm gonna set it the best and we're
actually gonna you know we're going to
work with the lighting so let's go to
effect and we're going to do some global
illumination so what we'll do is we will
make a new material go and set only the
luminance tab will load a material I'm
actually going to load this picture
again because what we're doing is we're
going to make a new sky I'm gonna apply
this material to the sky what's
happening is the planes you know are
accepting this scene so that you know
they're gonna be colored like a bluish
color so let's see what that looks like
when we render it'll give for a very
realistic render alright it's a little
dark let's go in here and let's set it
to add and let's take our
sky and right-click go to cinema 4d tags
and go to compositing we're going to
uncheck scene by camera so that when we
render let's actually turn the plane off
as well in the render view and when we
render it you won't have anything
interfering okay that's too bright so
let's just okay this is not working
let's set it to normal let's try like
50% because you can darken it you know
it just be kind of you know be a little
harder to brighten it so let's go to
materials and let's set a let's set the
specular on these planes so they're a
little more shiny we will do some
reflection like I don't know 10% and
we'll set blurriness to 5 I'll actually
blur out our HDRI image to 5 and 5 that
way you know it won't be like a perfect
reflection it would be kind of like a
blurred reflection so let's try it again
all right so the render time has
increased let's take that blur off on
everything we've done so far especially
on this reflection so it's a little
faster let's give it for the luminance
here let's bring this make it a little
more blue and we will give it like a
reflection of 15 and render that now
these Jets are gonna have motion blur
you can either add motion blur in in
After Effects or you can add it in
central 4d um I'm going to add it in
cinema 4d and I'm gonna happen to save
it as two different ones one with motion
blur and one without just me just in
case like the motion blur and cinema 4d
is really good if I can use that but if
I want to you know change it in a
perfect I can just use the one without
it you can actually render multi passes
for that you can just do let's see is
there motion blur in here somewhere
usually post effects yeah right here
post effects if you do a motion blur
object motion blur then you know I'll
apply it here 7:40 tags motion blur and
then I'll just control drag these to
these other jets I'll set you know it's
probably going to be a lot of motion
blur but you know tweak these settings
your strengths here and your strengths
here and you can actually toggle on and
off the motion blur because you save out
a multipass so you know check the multi
pass and we can do let's see check the
multi pass go to output I'm sorry go to
save and you have an option to save your
multi pass let's save it to our desktop
again
Jetts blur and once again we'll do a
quick time 29.97 millions of colors plus
animation best and we don't need to
worry about this and I think we are
ready to render alright so we're back in
After Effects let's import our footage
here
all right now you'll get this box up
here now this is for the Alpha channel
you need to ignore it and not have
enough channel you can use this or you
can use this now I think I'm not really
sure between these two the difference
but I think this has like a ring kind of
like an outer ring around it if it's an
explosion and it has a black ring around
it select this one and it'll probably
get rid of it
but we're just going to go with this for
this tutorial and let's bring our jets
down in here and the first thing you'll
notice is yes it is pre keyed for you so
cinema 4d is really good at that
cinema 14 after fix go very well
together so the first thing we need to
do is you see our jets here are not
motion tracked you know they can be
flying by and they're not stuck to the
footage so we need to motion track our
footage here so it's like the footage
workspace I'm already in motion tracking
we're going to click track motion we're
going to do position and we're also
going to do rotation so let's go back
here
I'm going to track this box up here I'm
actually probably gonna just track this
corner in this corner now I'm not really
good at tracking so I'm gonna have to go
and do it manually frame by frame just
because one it's blurry and two probably
won't get a good enough track so we'll
start here if you use the page up and
down keys you can switch between frames
so we'll set both of our points up here
and we're going to analyze one frame
forward notice they both went off the
points so I bring them back let's do it
again you're gonna keep doing this until
the video is finished now you're not
gonna have to do it and frame by frame
for the whole video because eventually
you know the camera will finish painting
and it'll be a little more easier for
these tracker points to stick on to what
you're trying to get the track to see
there it was pretty close so keep going
and keep moving these points frame by
frame see that one this one is pretty
much stuck on stuck on again alright now
what we can do is we can click play and
let's see if that gets us a good track
and it looks like it is now it might be
a little jittery but it won't really
matter because these planes are going by
really fast alright so we have our track
there now what we're gonna do is go to
the layer new a null object and we will
edit target and set this to null and
then okay we're going to apply probably
dimensions X&Y
close this we can hide this null object
and actually let's bring it back our
track starts on this frame so if you
hold alt and hit beginning bracket you
can start this here so well now we know
when to you know put these wind apparent
the Jets to the null so when we pan over
we would probably want to have maybe
these fly by a little earlier
yeah
maybe something like that so problem
with this is if we track it and our
cameras going up we're gonna get the
problem of and I'll show you if we track
it and parent it here to the null you
see that obviously does not look right
even though it's stuck to you know
photos pretty well it looks terrible
so let's undo that you want to keep in
mind you probably want to parent it when
the camera stops moving up so right
about here is when you can parent it
so take the Jets and parent it to the
null let's go back and you'll see that
they actually work this time and we get
this last guy and he has a problem here
so what we'll do is we can actually undo
that again and parent it right there so
that he has time to get by
all right um it looks yeah not that
great so I actually want the jet to come
in you know kind of as it's painting so
let's just move it back some yeah that's
cool and then that guy yeah that guy
makes it so let's save it always save
your project all right what can we do to
make this better
first we can mask it out here
so before we mask it let's get the speed
right
that's probably that's probably right I
mean that's you know they're going
pretty fast watts and motion blur but
let's mask it now so you know select our
jets footage go to the pen tool and
let's start masking this guy you want to
the way of I think you know I kind of
mixed up sometimes I think of it as the
area I'm selecting you know the circle
that I'm selecting is the area what I
want if that makes any sense so that's
why those planes disappeared so in the
jets here let's hit mmm and this is our
mask options here and let's we're going
to animate this path so click this and
we'll go forward one and we'll just
reset this I mean it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be that perfect just
as long as you get this
in this correct you'll be alright you
see our plane is starting to come in
starting to come over the roof here this
is filmed by a hunter restaurant that I
work at a Bochy Steakhouse pretty
awesome my girlfriend filmed this so
she's a she's proud of it turned out
pretty well I thought so thank you for
that let's see all right
so continue masking that uh this is the
most probably the most annoying part of
this thing and where is our second point
there is
all right so obviously we have to
stretch that out and get our guy come
about here so there's our mask once
again turn this off you can click here
so that looks okay just because we have
this here this is you know there's
motion blur but there's no motion blur
in this mask so we'll feather it like
that and we will also turn on motion
blur for these jets that way when the
camera pans
there's blur I'm jet and it looks very
realistic in my opinion depth of field
and motion blur will make pretty much
anything look fairly realistic so save
it out again and let's work on making
these jets look a little more realistic
you'll notice a couple of things let's
turn off motion blur and when we look at
this jet it looks too crisp so what I
always do let's go to effects here and
let's go type in mosaic just both at
wrong as a ik and we apply a mosaic
filter to the Jets first thing I notice
is obviously I'm very pixelated let's
set these to 300 by 300 pixels so
they're not you know the footage is is
kind of crappy to go along with my
crappy camera and you also notice that
my crappy camera has some grain and
these don't so let's add grain and we're
loading and we're loading and that that
is pretty good let's take the intensity
down to 0.5 all right let's take it back
up to 1 let's make his size 0.5 let's
take that back up to 1 I guess that'll
be good enough we will do we'll leave it
preview
just because I'm assuming if it has a
preview option final output would take
up a lot of time to render these frames
so we'll turn that off for now just get
rid of that annoying box but turn it
back on when you render so let's also
add a fast blur to these jets notice my
helmet here kind of blurred out or gonna
long over the sky we need to blur this
out a little bit more one will do it and
with our grain it's looking you know
pretty realistic it's fitting into the
scene I don't really think any color
correction needs to be made just because
you want to match one important thing is
you want to match the shadows you see
the shadows here you want to match them
here if they're too dark and these are
too light it's not gonna work you see
you can still kind of see my skin under
here it's not completely black same
prayer you can still kind of see the
gray it's not completely black keep that
in mind so we'll turn off on this add
grain effect for now and we'll look at
what we have
all right
getting there let's turn emotional go
back on for these airplanes is we want
to add some directional blur when these
are flying by so let's get some
directional blur for this and we'll set
it to say change the angle of 15 we'll
set it to 10 always want to look at
reference footage I looked at you know
reference footage on YouTube of planes
flying by they weren't really that
blurry when they flew by you can you
could tell what they were it wasn't just
a blob that kind of looked like a plane
you could you can see details as they
were flying by there's some blur you
know but not like ridiculousness like
this so keep that in mind always want a
reference you know realistic footage
that might even be well let's see let's
see what we got
I only have two gigs of RAM and two
processors so it's kind of you know kind
of slow when it comes to rendering and
whatnot hopefully I'll be upgrading soon
yeah that looks cool that looks very
cool now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take it off right as this planning
goes away so let's go here to our jets
hit you that'll bring up all weight we
had a mini hearson there right okay go
to the directional blur key frame and
we'll go the next frame and we'll set it
to zero because we don't want our plane
back here having directional blur
because it's it's you know it's still
going fast but it's high up in the sky
it's not going as fast as those first
two you know so let's see what this
looks like
very very cool I'm not like I'm liking
this I'm really liking this so let's
save this out and we will okay one thing
you can do before we add camera shake
and whatnot is when these jets are
falling by you can add streaks behind
here or you can add glow of the you know
the fire or the the exhaust coming out
of the back of the Jets you can do that
with like a particle system or you could
do that with you know as simple as a
white solid kind of like in the tracer
on tutorial make it a thin you know
narrow strip blur it out and just parent
it to this null and you might have a
cool effect but I'm not I'm not going to
add that in here we're gonna go to the
camera shake part so I'm gonna take all
this and hit ctrl shift C and that is
the new composition shortcut and we'll
call this flyby and it's edge some
camera shake will go here we will go
effect expression controls slider
control just like in the last video in
the last tutorial probably right about
here well in the reference footage in
the real footage when the plane flew by
it actually flew by first then the
camera shook so maybe about here with P
we will all click this will type wiggle
will go beginning bracket 8 comma brings
pickup to the slider and we will finish
that parentheses click off and now we
can start working with this so we'll get
here and we'll make a keyframe and we'll
go one two three and we'll really bring
this guy off we'll go maybe here and
let's keep it like that is that one
flies by
and we will get you down here make
another keyframe go one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
bring it down to zero most likely we're
probably gonna take those down because
it's a lot let's check it out
got the points fine bye it's like oh oh
dang camera shake and let's check it
it's not bad let's let's add a motion
tile bring it on here we'll set this to
like 130 to 130 mirror edges I'll get
rid of our problems here now we might
have some spots when you know right here
right here but I don't think it'll be
too much of a problem especially when we
add motion blur let's check this out
see if this looks cool let me have our
guy back here he's a little late for the
party and we will see what this looks
like
okay the camera shake dies too fast
let's bring it out
alright let's take the let's change us 8
to ace 5 that way there won't be as much
you know there won't be a bunch of
shakes there'll be bigger shakes but
just fewer fewer amounts of shake if
that makes any sense that looks pretty
cool now when you add sound effects to
this it's gonna be so awesome because I
mean half maybe more than half is all
about sound you can really sell it so
any final words let me think
make sure when you're on set if you're
gonna if you're if you're planning on
doing something like this you have
tracking markers like maybe it would
have been smart to put you know
something on these walls here or if I
didn't move put something on me you know
you always want to think ahead and think
how can I help myself later and shorten
the amount of time of the effect like if
the client wants it within a day and you
don't have track markers you know and
doesn't that it's gonna take you longer
than that so you want to try and save
yourself some time the planes they can
be made in probably any program you can
get for free at turbosquid like I said
motion blur depth of field will make
anything look pretty much pretty close
to realistic and always reference real
life footage because I mean it's real
life you can't get any more realistic so
try and mimic that like with the shake
it happened after the point went by just
keep those things in mind you know with
the shadows you just want to keep
everything in mind as you're building
scene and compositing things to make it
look as realistic as possible so thank
you this is my second tutorial and let's
take a look at the final the final image
or final video
you